he's an american motivational speaker
author and former television host as a
motivational speaker he uses a
catchphrase it's possible and encourages
people to chase their dreams he was the
host of the Les Brown show
he's Les Brown and here his top ten
rules for success I do a lot of training
for many corporations and I conduct
sales seminars and I've heard all kind
of guys doing techniques and training
people techniques of how to close sales
and how to work within and begin to
control the sale and how to ask for the
clothes let me share something with you
you can learn all the techniques in the
world if you don't believe in yourself
it won't happen for you I learned all of
it so that's why I do a training called
focus on the seller you've got to focus
on you and as you convince you as you
sell yourself every day every day every
day you will begin to see a difference
in the things that you're doing selling
yourself on your ability to perform a
job to achieve a certain objective
telling yourself every day here I go
again and I got what it takes this is my
day and nothing out here is going to
stop me it's necessary that you be
flexible that you are always thinking of
how can I improve this better this is a
customer driven economy it's necessary
for you to always explore various ways
in which you can improve the quality of
service that you're providing for the
people in your organization I remember
something a major company had talked
about the extra value service they were
providing for their customers and the
lady who had the news conference
summarized it this way she said it's not
our intention to satisfy our customers
or to please our customers our intention
is to amaze them it's necessary if
you're going to compete today that you
look for ways to amaze your customers by
being one of those individuals that keep
your commitments that keep your word
that's relentless it's necessary you
work with the people that you bring into
all your
nation that they see that you are a good
example of a person to work with because
you model integrity and determination
and ambition and truth and honesty and
the way in which you conduct business
the other thing is take full
responsibility for your life except
where you are and the responsibility
that you're going to take yourself where
you want to go so once that we have two
primary choices in life
we can either accept conditions as they
exist or we can take the responsibility
to change them see a lot of people want
to exempt themselves from taking
responsibility all they want to do is
talk about the problem every time you
see them they'll tell you their story
over and over and over and over again no
no you want to take responsibility for
your life
I got me here I can get me out of this
and I'm getting out I'm not going to be
a volunteer victim George Bernard Shaw
said there are two kinds of people in
life you know he said those that make
things happen those that watch things
happen and those that don't know what
happened
and he said the people to get alone in
this life look around for the
circumstances that they want and if they
can't find them they make up they
creator so part of beginning to get
unstuck you've got to decide that the
behavior pattern that you have adopted
doesn't work for you you've got to
change your strategies and changing your
strategy means reinventing your life
recreating you and you have the power to
do that you can decide that you're going
to change that you're not going to be a
wimp
you can decide that you're going to
stand up to life you can decide that I'm
going to live each day as if it were my
last you can you have the power to make
that decision
you can decide I'm going to work on
myself and develop myself I'm going to
empower me and all of these things that
are happening to me right now
they're just temporary inconveniences
they're not stronger than I am I'm in
charge here
overcoming the negative conversation
that inner dialog is going on all the
time all the time even when you don't
want it to be there you can't stop
yourself right now from thinking you
can't do it it's going on and so
learning how to empower yourself part of
doing that is standing up to yourself
you've got to stand up inside yourself
sometimes and say shut up
you've got to do this I was going to
give a presentation and this voice
inside of me saying you can't do this
you don't have everything it takes I
shut up I'm behind on my bills and you
telling me what I can't do I have got to
do it
you get scared sometimes your mind will
go blank on you
some people will you will allow to
unnerve you and you wonder what's wrong
with me I'm not crazy that's why you've
got to learn to make a conscious
deliberate determined effort to stand up
inside yourself working on yourself
watching that inner dialogue it will
determine the quality of your life
next thing is that you've got to
activate the thinker in you don't allow
your emotions to control you we are
emotional but we you want to begin to
discipline your emotion if you don't
discipline and contain your emotions
they will use you your mind goes on
automatic just like a god you know I
loved reading the book call has a man
take it by James Allen he uses the
analogy of the mind being like a garden
you know weeds don't have to have any
encouragement to grow you don't have to
water them they don't have to get
sunshine they don't have to have fertile
ground they will grow through the cracks
of a sidewalk am i right but if you want
to grow orchids or roses or any kind of
exotic flowers there are special
processes and procedures you must go
through what by the same token you don't
have to force yourself or motivate
yourself to think negatively to be
depressed to hate somebody to want
revenge you want to get back at somebody
to beat yourself up over the head to
feel loaded with guilt you don't have to
make any effort to do that your mind is
on automatic it will do that by itself
but if you want to begin to move into
your own personal greatness if you want
to begin to really enjoy a happy
successful healthy life you've got to be
willing to go against the tide you've
got to be willing to harness your will
and say in spite of this I'm in control
here I'm not going to let this get me
down I'm not going to let this destroy
me I'm coming back and I'll be stronger
and better because of it you have got to
make a declaration that this is what you
stand for
are you're standing up for your dreams
you're standing up for peace of mind
you're standing up for health you want
it and you're going to go all out to
have it it's not going to be easy when
you want to change it's not easy if it
were in fact easy everybody to do it but
if you're serious you'll go all out I
don't care how good you are until how
care how talented you are I don't care
how much you work on yourself there
sometimes when things aren't going to go
right they just I'm not going to go
right there are times with anything that
can happen will happen Murphy's Law will
be knocking at your door why I don't
know why that's called life and you have
to deal with it sometimes your life will
be in a slump just like sports some of
the best shooters can't hit baskets
different times and games they get in a
slump do they sit on the sidelines and
say you know jested hit a basket today
no they continue to execute I suggest to
you that if you were facing a challenge
don't stop stay busy work your plan
continue to do those things that you
know that work for you after you have
evaluated yourself in the situation
continue to move stay busy stay busy
stay busy I was working on a job and I
came home one day I was married at the
time
not old my former wife I said that guy
Berta I work for is stupid she said if
he's so stupid why does he sign your
paycheck
now you see why I divorced er right
I couldn't stand her that night I could
not sleep well here was a guy that was
controlling my life I was going through
all kind of changes because this man
controlled my paycheck and it was
Carlyle who said truth crushed to earth
shall rise again Winston Churchill said
the truth is incontrovertible malice
mere tacit ignorant smae derided but at
the end there is and we know scripture
that says he shall know the truth and
the truth shall set you free and the
truth that I had to come to grips with
that I wasn't in charge of my destiny
the truth was that I wasn't giving all
that I had the truth was that there are
some things that I wanted to do but I
didn't have the courage to act on those
things and the truth was that Birchall's
was a blessing to me he made life so
miserable for me I had to start looking
at my life differently I started going
to work earlier I started being the last
one to leave there I started working
harder than anybody else the other guys
could not why would you work so hard
less I said I'm not working for them I
have been cheating Burt I thought I've
been cheating myself and my family
wherever you are whatever you're doing
doing with everything that you have
develop the habit of giving more than
what you're paid for develop the habit
of setting standards that others will be
measured by someone says do not go where
the path may lead but go where there is
no path and leave a trail that in the
process of working on your dreams you
are going to incur it incur a lot of
disappointment a lot of failure a lot of
pain a lot of setbacks a lot of defeats
but in the process of doing that you
will discover some things about yourself
that you don't know right now what you
will realize is that you have greatness
within you what you'll realize is that
you're more powerful than you can ever
begin to imagine what you will realize
is that you're greater than your
circumstances that you don't have to go
through life being a victim if Jack
indicated I was born in Miami Florida in
the area called Liberty City in an
abandoned building on a hardened Olien
floor with my twin brother we were six
weeks of age we were adopted when I was
in 5th graders identified as EMR labeled
educable mentally [ __ ] put back from
the fifth grade into the fourth grade
and stayed in that category until I got
out of high school I don't have any
college training but I met a high school
teacher who one day changed my life I
was waiting on another student and when
he came in he said to me young man go to
the board and write what I'm about to
tell you and I said I can't do that turn
he said why not I said I'm not one of
your students he said it doesn't matter
follow my directions down and say I
can't do that sir he said why not I said
because I magica bula mentally [ __ ]
and he came from behind his desk and he
looked at me he said don't ever say that
again
someone's opinion of you does not have
to become your reality I'm saying this
is the time more than ever that you want
to begin to inoculate yourself with
positive words coming to conventions
showing up on meetings being on the
calls to make yourself unstoppable to
get out of your mind the polluting
negative thoughts that's causing most
people to go through life being stuck
because they're volunteer victims
somebody said that many people died aged
25 and don't get buried until they're 65
because they got so much garbage in
their minds you are here because you've
got a clear vision of what you want and
where you're going give yourselves a
round of applause come on bring energy
level up
yes yes you want more you want more
you're different you're different than
everybody else don't worry if they don't
get it don't try and convince people to
do this business a person convinced
against their will is of the same
opinion still you are not like everybody
else you can walk outside and find
pigeons but if you're looking for Eagles
it's going to take you a minute you are
different it's lonely at the top how
many of you know as long they at the top
razor has it's lonely at the top but you
eat better that's what I'm talking about
you're different
one great entrepreneur said I choose not
to be a common man it's my right to be
uncommon if I can I'll seek opportunity
not security I do not wish to be a kept
citizen humbled and dull by having the
state look after me I want to take the
calculated risk to dream and to bill to
fail and to succeed I refuse to live
from hand to mouth I prefer the
challenges of life to the guaranteed
existence the thrill of fulfilment to
the still calm of utopia I would never
cower before a master nor been to any
threat it's my heritage to stand erect
proud and unafraid the face the world
boldly and say this I have done you
showed up because you're building a
business that you can stand and say I
did this I did this this is my dream
give yourselves a round of applause yes
yes yes yes it's hard changing your life
it was hard when just over three years
ago and the Penobscot building in
Detroit Michigan where I was operating
my business and I fell on some hard
times and I was sleeping in my office
it was hard coming into the lobby and
the security said scuse me mr. Brown can
we see you for a moment and I said yes
and I walked up to the counter and he
gave me an envelope and he said would
you mind reading it here and I opened
the envelope and the envelope was from
management that says this is an office
tower it's not a hotel please do not
sleep in your office and I said excuse
me sir I said I just worked long hours
in creating my business I'm an
entrepreneur and right now things are
bad for me but they're not going to be
this way always and I just asked for the
opportunity to continue to operate like
I'm doing I'm not trying to make this my
home and it was hard coming through the
lobby and sometimes they would laugh
there's a guy talking about becoming
successful and look at him he's bathing
in the bathroom upstairs on the 21st
floor he sleeps on the floor him and two
other dreamers up there look at him
it was hard ladies and gentlemen coming
to speak to people and I was facing
financial difficulties in my own life I
was behind on my bills and my dreams and
I'm saying to them you can live your
dream it was hard ladies and gentlemen
it was very difficult to pick myself up
each day believing that I can do it
there were times that I doubted myself
and say God why why is this happening to
me I'm just trying to take care of my
children and my mother I'm not trying to
steal a Rob from anybody how did this
have to happen to me it was very hard
and here's what I want to say to you for
those of you that have experienced some
hardships
don't give up on your dream no one could
have convinced me by holding on by
continuing to push forward by continuing
to run toward my dream that one day I
would have my own talk show it's a long
shot ladies and gentlemen from Liberty
City an abandoned building on the floor
never knowing my mother or father it's a
long shot
being here with you today in this Dome
in Atlanta it's a long shot
no college training labeled educable
mentally [ __ ] but i kept running
toward my dream
don't stop
Goldstar
don't stop running toward your dream
thank you so much for watching I made
this video because demo healthcare asked
me to so if there's a famous
entrepreneur that you want me to profile
next leave it in the comments below and
I'll see what I can do
I'd also love to know which of Les
Brown's top ten rules hit you the
hardest he's one of my favorite speakers
so I'd love to know which the ten points
meant most to you leave it in the
comments below and I'll join in the
discussion thank you so much for
watching
continue to believe and I'll see you
soon
program your mind deliberately the
reason that most people don't achieve
their goals is because they are thinking
like everybody else sixteen
revolutionary words be not conformed to
this world be transformed by the
renewing of your mind
that's an on-going process what are your
goals what are your dreams ro
Nightingale was right you don't get in
life what you want you get in life what
you are and so you want to take the time
every day to listen to things that can
help to program your mind positively
because at the end of the day if you
don't program your mind it's going to be
programmed trust me it's going to be
bombarded with all kind of hair trash
commercials I was at a service station
pumping gas and a commercial came up I
mean you get on the elevator and
commercials are there you look at
billboards there messages coming in over
5,000 10,000 messages on a regular basis
and so as you look at your goals and
dreams it's very important that you are
intentional about controlling what goes
on in your mind because everything gets
in through the eyes and through the ears
so what do you want what do you want for
yourself what I'm doing right now I
didn't do it for 14 years you know why
because I was suffering from possibility
blindness have you thought about doing
something and you you looked at what you
wanted to do and your heart said I could
do that and then your mind asked how and
then you start thinking well
I can't do that I don't have a college
education I can't do that I don't have
an MBA or a PhD I can't do that I've
never worked for a major corporation
about why would corporations reach over
people with PhDs and MBAs and years of
experience and pay me to come in to do
something I've never done I thought
about doing this for years and I talked
myself out of it yes an African proverb
that says if there's no enemy within the
enemy outside can do us no harm
Shakespeare says the fort dear Brutus
it's not or not stars but in ourselves
that we are underlings and so as you
look at yourself and look at your goals
and look at your dreams I'm saying to
you that it's possible because if
anybody at any point in time had a goal
had a dream of what they wanted to
achieve and they made it happen then
it's possible that you can do it too
you've got to be intentional about
programming your mind it's necessary
that you detoxify your life that you
have to look at your life and look at
the people in your life and Jim Rohn
said ask the question what is this
relationship doing to me
see most people never live their dreams
because they are saddled with too many
toxic negative energy draining people in
their lives now look at the people
around you and ask is this this
relationship is it helping me to grow
mentally emotionally financially
spiritually on a financial part MIT did
a study you earned within two to three
thousand dollars of your closest friends
it's necessary if you are serious about
your dream that you detoxify your life
dr. Dennis Kim rod of Atlantis ed if you
are the smartest one in your group you
need to get a new group what I heard
that I got all the broke people out my
life because people rub off on you John
H Johnson who had a loan of $500 from
his mother and built a four hundred
million dollar Empire with ebony
magazine and Jet magazine fired his best
friend and and the report asked why did
you fire your best friend he said he
told me I couldn't do it he's in hell I
didn't think I could do it I need
anybody on my payroll to tell me so you
have to look at your life and say hey
who's in my circle who's in my ear the
only reason that most of us don't
accumulate a level of achievement in our
lives
one most people end up aiming low that's
what I did most of my life that most
people fail in life not because they aim
too high I miss most people fail in life
because they aim too low and hit and
that's what I did I was a disc jockey I
was very satisfied I achieved a level of
professionalism and mastery in that area
and then someone challenged means that
you can do more and it took him 14 years
to convince me to become this person
that you now see this person that you
now see this voice which I consider my
power voice I had absolutely no idea
that this person existed but there are
some times in life someone can take you
to a place within yourself where you can
never go by yourself and he saw
something in me and sometimes you have
to believe in somebody's belief in you
until your belief kicks in